This year, wireless earbuds have been a real big buzz topic.
We've seen a couple of companies, a couple of start-ups try their efforts,...
...and now we're looking at Samsung's new Gear IconX,...
...and these are truly wireless earbuds.
They just sit in your ear.
They can stream music to your ears...
...and they can also track a whole bunch of fitness things.
Really, the fitness angle is what Samsung's big pitch here is.
They can track your distance, your heart rate.
It can interpret your calories burned, stuff like that,...
...and it syncs with Samsung's S Health app on your phone,...
...but it can also do all that stuff stand-alone.
Now, these little earbuds come in a case, like you can see here,...
...which charges them, provides 2X battery charge on there,...
...but then they'd pop into your ear like so, when they'll automatically turn on.
You've got some basic commands on your touchpad here.
Very similar to the Bragi Dash in terms of shape and size,...
...but they are really small, really light...
...and they're really easy to fit into your ear.